malta ist nationalsport in thailand
schon elfjährige stehen sich wie hier im
nordosten des landes im boxring
gegenüber und kämpfen um ruhm und
preisgelder umgerechnet etwa 38 euro
kriegen diese jungs pro kampf bei einem
sieg noch einmal um die 77 euro als
siegprämie dazu für viele familien in
thailand ein willkommenes extra die
jungen boxer hoffen auf eine
profikarriere und damit auf eine chance
ihre familien aus der armut zu holen und
das hat in den letzten jahren immer mehr
junge thaiboxer angezogen
fachleute sehen diesen trend zunehmend
kritisch die gesundheit der kinder stehe
auf dem spiel sagen ärzte wie die
neurologin therapon laut thomas in einer
von ihr durchgeführten studie hat sie
hirnschäden und gedächtnis schwächen bei
den jungen boxern nachgewiesen
es gibt kein sicheres boxen und kann es
bei den erwachsenen boxen sehen sie
kriegen parkinson verursacht durch die
hirnschäden beim boxen bei den kindern
drohen die unter entwicklung des gehirns
und andere schäden das wirkt sich
wesentlich schwerer aus die expertin
fordert ein verbot der vollkontakt
kämpfe für kinder unter elf jahren davon
sind eltern und trainer wenig begeistert
sie sagen der sport vermittelt den
kindern disziplin und halte sie von der
straße fern
außerdem glauben viele schläge und
tritte der kinder hätten noch nicht
genug kraft um schäden anzurichten
trotz der warnungen der fachleute